huit hectares pour apprendre le métier
de maraîcher primer c'est l'objectif de
la ferme école graines d'avenir de magny
les hameaux
elle organisait des portes ouvertes
mercredi 9 juin pour recruter ses futurs
étudiants mais également pour présenter
le concept de l'établissement la
ferme-école graines d'avenir associé
agro écologie et enseignement l'innovant
pour former des jeunes dès 15 ans au
métier de maraîcher primer les jeunes
vont être mises en situation de vivre le
métier de maraîcher primeur et vont
passer deux tiers de leur temps à faire
de la pratique ils vont satisfaire à des
vraies commandes de vrais clients au
prix du marché et pendant un tiers du
temps restant ils vont apprendre des
enseignements théoriques installée sur
le site historique de bulles loyer et
appartenant à l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
le site était inoccupée puis en
réhabilitation depuis 2016 depuis mars
on est en train de remettre en
exploitation la ferme l'objectif est
d'avoir une exploitation en
fonctionnement en septembre octobre
autre objectif de graines d'avenir être
un écosystème entre les territoires les
jeunes et les entreprises pour les
territoires on va lutter contre le
décrochage scolaire on va lutter contre
le chômage des jeunes pour les
entreprises on va mettre sur le marché
des jeunes qui sont formés et rapidement
opérationnelles spécifiquement aux
métiers et enfin pour les jeux on va
leur proposer une troisième voie
complémentaire entre le lycée
professionnel et le cfa la ferme école
accueillera donc douze jeunes par
promotion pour une formation de trois
ans à l'issue de celle ci deux diplômes
leur seront délivrés ans et ap primeur
ainsi qu'un titre professionnel
d'ouvriers de production horticole pour
découvrir une autre journée portes
ouvertes est organisée le 23 juin
prochain